[Music]
hey everybody
i hope everybody's recovered from last
night's show yeah
i didn't actually get all that drunk
last night i guess that i guess that
irish cream knockoff stuff wasn't
wasn't that alcoholic yeah because i i
was like a little bit drunk by now that
i got loaded
yes it's fine though
yeah i'm just i i decided to leave
because the show ended up being in two
parts on the video obviously because uh
because our stream got cut off at about
three hours in
um i decided to leave the videos the way
they are because it would just take too
long for me to like download the videos
and then put
edit them together and then upload it
back again um but the audio version i
actually did put all the audio together
so if you listen to us over audio
um then you'll hear you'll hear it as
one
continuous show with like at the end of
the first thing i'm like what happened
what happened what happened and then
like a couple seconds later i come back
and be like okay it all [ __ ] up you
know
yeah so it all kind of went something
about our internet connection
was really bad yesterday it's a lot
better right yeah i kept getting because
if you're streaming like on youtube you
know it'll say like how good your
connection is like today i have
excellent connection last night i kept
getting poor connection like a little
yellow light all the time
yeah um so there's some kind of problem
with the big tech firms you know
they're doing [ __ ] right now it's weird
i didn't have um
i didn't have a problem on either of my
other two computers
um with the internet it was just on this
one
i'm not really sure why because i did
[ __ ] on the other two computers all day
long and didn't have a problem
but for some reason this the laptop that
we stream on was just kind of like nope
not having it
um but yeah so we were just discussing
uh because i know all of you guys that
were here last night we were talking
about
doing essentially like a side tracks
show again
and maybe doing that once a week and
doing it in the evening um
the same as we do the regular shows but
not having a topic
so we can just kind of like go off and
do whatever the [ __ ] we want
i'm i would propose since i don't
necessarily
want to because i like kind of having
two days where we don't stream so i can
have a break i mean we do i do put
recorded [ __ ] up on those days
but i like having two days where i you
know where i can have a break and not
have to stream
so i feel like maybe what we should do
is not do a movie review on wednesday
and instead do like a topic-less stream
on like wednesday even like at 5 00 pm
eastern standard time yeah you mean a
free stream
it doesn't have yeah yeah it's just
interactive yeah
all right maybe it might maybe it might
have something to do
with a current event just to open the
show or something something like that
you know it might it's just gonna be
a situational like msr therapeutic
[ __ ] streams gonna have [ __ ] music
going in the background probably like
vaporwave or some kind of music and it's
just gonna be fun stream they would just
drink and
talk [ __ ] yeah it's gonna be funny i
thought wednesday evening would be good
because it's like the middle of the week
like halfway in between
yeah and we were already doing a movie
review on wednesday and i was like well
we can just do
we don't have to do a movie review on
wednesday we can just do like a topic
list
like a free form show wednesday evening
then we can have a drink and it's like
halfway
answer questions about the paranormal or
[ __ ] unsolved mysteries just anything
yeah we can just talk about anything and
not worry about then i won't have to
worry about taking notes and we don't
we won't have to watch as many movies
during the week if we don't want to
it's actually it takes load off of us
and i think you guys would like it more
yeah yeah yeah and i just think that
would be a good
you know right that'd be good i wanted
to have really good audio visual to it
like i'm gonna have the [ __ ] set up in
the back
speaking of which you didn't turn the
party laser on yeah hold on turn the
party laser yeah we're
gonna start the [ __ ] party
oh that's right i forgot i gotta plug it
in yeah you have to unplug it because
it is plugged in you just have it off on
the back yet we just always have to turn
it off because it has a fan and it makes
like a really loud noise the fan is
really loud for whatever reason
look at it go slow that [ __ ] down
there you go like it's slow
i like it slow like it's slow
[Laughter]
okay there you go tom's a black man in a
white man's body exactly
who said that [ __ ] i don't know i did
you said that i just
[Laughter]
all right so let me talk about this
movie and then if you want to talk about
some stuff because i
because you didn't really see this movie
i think you just saw the very very yeah
i was busy
and you didn't know like what was going
on so it didn't really yeah what was i
doing
i was cooking you were either you were
either cooking or you were in the gym or
yeah jim i think i came back i don't
remember like it had already been it
would
have
been and it was like already almost over
because it was it was not a super long
way it was only uh 93 minutes it was
only an hour and a half or something
like that
uh so this is a netflix original
called his house and i've been meaning
to watch this for a really long time and
then
um but i kept you know finding other
things and i was just like oh this looks
good or whatever and then
i was watching a whole bunch of other
horror channels and a lot of people had
this on their you know best horror of
the year list so i'm like okay well i
have to sit down and watch it now so i
just went ahead and
watched it and i will say i can see why
a lot of people put this on their best
of horror list because this was pretty
[ __ ]
good um so basically here's the story
and i
don't want to because this is new this
is from 2020
um i think it originally premiered at
like sundance or something like that
but i think netflix maybe put it up just
a month or two ago it
hasn't been up that long so basically so
i'm not gonna spoil it
because there is some [ __ ] in here that
you know it would kind of
you know um so the story is there's
these two there's this couple
bull and rial and they're from sudan
and they are seeking asylum in the uk
in london so they basically they get
there
and you're led to believe that during
the journey over
um the boat they were on capsized and
they lost
their daughter naya
so um but this has happened like a year
ago i guess they've been like in a
detention facility or whatever and then
finally like the authorities are like
okay
you know congratulations you know we're
gonna give you a little bit of a house
and a little bit of a stipend and you're
on like probation to see if you can stay
or whatever
and they give them this big long list of
rules um you know [ __ ] you can and can't
do
and stuff like that so they go to this
house which is actually really large but
it's in like really shitty condition
there's like all this garbage in front
of it and like all the [ __ ] it's
you know and the electricity isn't on
but they're like oh we'll fix it but
they never fix it so the guy has to fix
it himself
but it very shortly turns out as they
are trying to get uh
kind of acclimated to this new country
and this you know house that they're
living in you know this is a culture
that's very
alien to them so while they're getting
acclimated to that
probably within the first 10 15 minutes
um
turns out that this house not
surprisingly is [ __ ] haunted
now the interesting thing about this i
really really like
in a lot of ways it's like a haunted
house story but they kind of went a
different direction with it
in the sense that this house is
haunted by something called an
apeth i think they call it uh
essentially it's called a night witch
and this is sort of like a demon
or some kind of spirit or something
that's that attaches itself to you
when you've done something [ __ ] up um
in the sense that you've stolen
something uh because that's kind of one
of the stories that she tells about you
know about it that
you know it attaches itself to a thief
or something so the interesting thing is
this whole movie
you're seeing all this creepy [ __ ] like
happening in their house and all the
ghosts and [ __ ] like are really really
creepy like because they start like
coming out of the walls and like all
this kind of [ __ ]
you know creepy [ __ ] happening and so
but you find out
that there is a reason that this spirit
has
attached itself to them because at first
i'm not going to spoil it like i said
but what you were led to believe about
what happened when they came over
at first is not entirely the case
so when you find out later what really
happened
it puts into context why this particular
demon or spirit or whatever it is has
attached itself to them
and you know what they have to do to
fight it so i think like the cool thing
about this
it's like a haunted house story but it
also has like a much deeper
meaning to it that's um you know kind of
about
about grief about establishing a new
life and [ __ ] like that but it
it doesn't do it like in a real
ponderous or in your face kind of way
it's still scary
and it's still you know it has really
great creepy imagery has really really
great characters that you really feel
for
um and it has just really great i love
some of the imagery is like kind of
surrealist
you know what i mean like there's one
part where um where bowl like is like
sitting at the table and all of a sudden
he just he perceives that he's just in
you know sitting at the table and
there's like a piece of a wall
and then like behind him it's like the
ocean and then like all these [ __ ]
zombies like start coming up out of the
ocean and stuff so it has like all these
really cool
um visuals like that that are kind of
surrealistic
i also really like some like some of the
little touches like
um there's one scene where rial goes out
and she's trying to find the doctor's
office and like the guy from the council
or whatever has drawn her
this little map and she's trying to find
it but she can't get out of the estate
it's almost kind of and it almost gave
me like a weird vivarium kind of vibe
for a second because she's like walking
around the wall
and then there's a kid like kicking a
soccer ball against the wall and then
she's like what and that's a dead end
and then she goes back this way
and now the kid's kicking the soccer
ball but he's like on this side now
like like how the [ __ ] did he get over
there so it's like this really cool
um you know it's almost like a visual
representation of how like alienated she
feels
you know how weird this place is and she
can't like figure it out
and so i like those little like
surrealist touches like that but yeah
this was like
this was a really really good one i
enjoyed this one a lot um like i said
the characters were great the acting was
great
and this was actually the first um i
guess the first
uh movie that was written and directed
by what
what is their name i saw it up here oops
whoops um
okay now never mind i don't know i
thought i had it written down but i
guess not
um yeah i don't know i'll find it out
weeks is their last name
yeah yeah yeah but yeah so this is uh
this is their first movie and it's like
really really good this has been getting
a lot of buzz and i can totally see why
i really really like the um
i really like the the ghosts because
there's a [ __ ] ton of them
and the dude that is the apath like you
don't see him really until like fully
until the end and it's like the makeup
on it is [ __ ] amazing
and it's the same guy he's that spanish
guy that was in the slenderman movie and
he's been in guillermo del toro movies
and stuff like that because he's like
super scrawny so they always put him in
like those
those monster outfits and stuff and he
looks [ __ ] great in this
like the makeup and [ __ ] is really
really good but yeah this is really uh
if you have netflix and you haven't
watched this one yet
i mean i i liked it a lot so i would
recommend it
if you want kind of a different a little
bit of a different spin on a haunted
house story
you know i thought it was like pretty
cool pretty creepy i didn't even get to
see it
i know well i can't give an opinion on
uh mango asks matt smith is in it yeah
he's not in it as [ __ ] on
uh he was one of the doctor who's right
um
yeah he's in it he's like the guy the
main guy that's like coordinating their
you know their counsel [ __ ] so he's
maybe in like three or four scenes or
something like that but yeah he is in it
so like a little bit at the beginning in
the end
they're asking me about the coding
picture yeah there's a there's a skull
in it
and then there's like a grim reaper over
there with the skull and he's got a hood
on it
there's kind of like when when it's not
got normal lighting on it it's not real
it's not real visible from what i
remember i've had normal lighting on
in a long time but they're just kind of
like
spirits of the dead and uh you know the
specter of death over him you know
and then he's standing on top of a dick
with a [ __ ]
i guess a mountain of dead bodies and
skulls and
he's got his [ __ ] hot little princess
on him it was a
it you know it was the cover to one of
the
one of the uh the books that yeah
you know rosetta did rosetta was a
commercial artist he did
covers for all kinds of stuff but i
don't i've never read
you know somebody asked me if i'd never
read any conan books like the
uh uh from the original author no i
haven't
robert howard robert howard yeah i've
never read it right never read any of it
a lot of notes
yeah there's a lot of difference but i
kind of grew up watching the movies
and the old marvel comic books yeah
because
when i was a kid you know when i was
reading that [ __ ]
but uh yeah maybe i i don't like reading
anymore
my eyes aren't aren't very good and
after my head injury my eyeballs kind of
jump around from one line to the next i
have a hard time
doing it um and then i
after like a day of reading i'll put it
down and forget to continue reading i
have to continue to remember myself to
go back and read it
but um yeah because i gave you that
billy idol book i got about halfway
through
you seemed like you were really into it
and then i forgot about it you forgot
yeah i forgot it existed well it seems
like you know
you're at least for me my real reading
time you know the era in which i read a
lot of books
was like between 16 and 19. i read a lot
of [ __ ] books during that
then joined the army and stopped reading
and just just did
you know read the internet now
i used to read a lot of of books and
then for a few years i kind of did it
because i had a lot of other projects
and i didn't have time
that's why deliberately i started doing
the new show because i was like man i
really need to get back into
[ __ ] reading again because i used to
really like enjoy that so i guess that
i mean and i like reading physical books
i will read an ebook and i have done but
um
and i i way prefer like reading an
actual physical book so i will actually
buy it rather than
yeah reading reading books is like an
entertainment medium of its own
you know i used to really enjoy it
because your imagination could take you
yeah you just get immersed and you just
in your own head it's like it's cool i
like
king and tripped me out i read most of
that damn gunslinger series i think i
read like three or four of those books
i've never finished the whole series
though but the dark tower series and
i don't think i did either now that you
mention it and then i was reading a
bunch of history books
freaking i read the entire
[ __ ] uh decline and fall of the roman
empire not the little abridged one but
the [ __ ] three huge [ __ ] books
that was [ __ ] tough to get through
just you see how history just repeats
itself over and over again and you
you're like oh yeah here's more of the
things yeah then a new guy would appear
in history and go i bet you he'll make a
difference and
no he gets killed [ __ ] he gets killed
like this is the worst movie ever yeah
he got killed a couple paragraphs later
and you're gonna go on like damn
gibbon i think his name was edward
gibbon who wrote that yeah
or gibbon or gibbons given their givens
yeah and uh you know
the preface you know talking about how
he went through all the damn
manuscripts and looked at all the
manuscripts that survived in up in the
attics of the [ __ ]
european nobility that went all the way
but they've been keeping it from all the
way back to the roman days
passed down you know it's [ __ ]
because they had still had books
left over he's right in the 1700s yeah
and then all the statues he'd looked at
and he talked about that
some of the statues were squirreled away
and he couldn't see him you know i mean
they wouldn't let him
like the owners would not even let him
see the damn statue
maybe he lied about having statues but
he wanted to know what these people look
like
you know and uh but it's just that was
interesting i think it was three books
they were each one of them was over a
thousand yeah if i remember correctly
yeah hardcover and then um
but after you get up to a certain age
it's kind of like
for me i kind of burned out on that
medium i don't know why
you become more physically active i
think more physically involved with life
i did because i was in the army and that
was it
you know man after that i liked movies
and audiobooks and
doing my own [ __ ] you know instead of
reading about other people's [ __ ]
it's weird though because i don't really
oh you know i'll listen to audiobooks
if it's kind of short like i don't mind
listening to like short stories and
stuff like that
but if i i don't like listening to
novels in an audiobook because my mind
will wander if i'm actually reading it
myself
then i'm able to like you know get
immersed in it and you know my
imagination goes crazy and stuff
and ces was saying earlier it's like
disappointing when you read a book and
then the movie comes out and it never
looks like what it looked like in your
head
which yeah that's something that i've
tangled with like pretty much all the
time i think if you guys watched
did i post it already um the review that
i did of that book the ruins by scott
smith
that was one that i actually saw the
movie first and then
later i was kind of like oh that's a
book i should read that because so many
people recommended it because like the
book is really good
and the book is really good the book's
like amazing but i really really wish
that i had read the book before i saw
the movie the movie is pretty good too
and uh the movie
but i think that since i saw the movie
first that was kind of informing
my reading of it that's like how i
pictured all the characters even though
they changed some of the characters up
um
from the book to the movie but that's
you know i kind of wish
what i'm trying to think of one really
egregious oh i remember what it was
i read that uh gigantic doorstop of a
book atonement
who wrote that ian mcewen i want to say
and it's like it was so good like i
loved that [ __ ] book
and then the movie came out and one
thing that i noticed
if i've read the book and then i go and
see the movie like the movie was good
but it seems like everything in the
movie
like happened like right away and i was
like wait what is this happening already
because in the book it took such a long
time like and
you know all this [ __ ] like developed
and everything but then in the movie it
seems like everything's just happening
like too quickly because they have to
cram everything in there
so i think that's kind of something that
i mean a book that long
it seems kind of difficult to that that
needs
it needs a series victor said he was
listening to the unseen hand audio book
while he was driving around
doing home health stuff that's cool yeah
that's
unseen hands a creepy [ __ ] collection
of stuff
it's even creepier when you've seen it
you're seeing that phenomenon yourself
but uh yeah although you know i don't
i i worked with you through that whole
thing i don't think i've actually
listened to the audiobook
no you probably haven't yeah i mean i
have it somewhere
yeah if you want to listen to
it um you know i've i've actually
started enjoying
reading audiobooks and you know i i
enjoy doing the witching hour show too
because i really really like like all
those old like creepy ghost stories and
stuff and i really really like reading
those
and i feel like my reading has gotten a
lot better you know
i gotta go back and finish the billy
idol [ __ ] autobiography i know
when did i i bought you that for
christmas like a year and a half ago or
your birthday or something was your
birthday yeah i think you have your
birthday but
not your last birthday was the birthday
before was it it's just man the time
goes by so fast i'm gonna be dead soon
anyway man it's going by so fast that's
the spirit
yeah i don't really have a concept of
time you know anymore the older you get
the faster the [ __ ] [ __ ] flies by i
don't even care though
i don't care well it's not like there's
like i said there's not like there's
anything you can do
it's not like you can stop time yeah
yeah
i i'm more afraid of just getting old
and infirm than death
i don't give a [ __ ] about death i'm just
going to have that out of body
experience i've had it before
well yeah that's what i think one with
the phone honestly i think most people
are more if you really kind of drill
down i think most people are more afraid
of like pain
or yeah or long-term suffering than they
are of actual death
yeah or just getting so old you can't do
anything but i've noticed that some
people when people get that
old they're not real mentally active
anyway they're just
it's kind of like they start shutting
down yeah they're mentally shutting down
because it's your brain being like yeah
we're
not checking it out so it's kind of like
part of the dynamic let's turn off all
the lights on the way out it's kind of
like that
it's like a slow motion and but to them
it probably doesn't feel like it's in
slow motion i bet you
their sense of time is so shot from
their point of view it feels like they
[ __ ] shut down and died in a matter
of a few days probably
yeah they probably just feel real sleepy
yeah like a waking tree
i don't know sandra asked do i still
record the stuff while i'm sitting in
the wardrobe
um it i i do record in the closet still
i don't usually do the witching hour
show in there because it's like kind of
a big production i usually just do that
right at my desk
but yeah if we turn the closet into a
sound booth yeah and
um so now because it used to be we just
had like muffled [ __ ] blankets
and [ __ ] like yeah so i had to like
crawl in there it was like 400 degrees
it's so ridiculous i can't [ __ ]
believe that we did that but like so the
inside of the closet now has all that um
that egg cartony yeah you know foam um
kind of all on the inside i insulated
the hole inside put a shelf
and then you put a shelf so um so i can
put my laptop and then
the microphone comes down from the
ceiling so it's all set up in there i
don't have to let go so i just go in
there put my laptop on the shelf and i
can actually stand
because i told him it's like i don't
like to yeah i don't like to sit like
that while i'm recording because i feel
like it's not i like to be able to move
around
yeah and stand up so uh so yeah it's a
lot but it's still kind of hot in there
in the summertime but what are you gonna
do you know yeah um
at least i don't have to sit in there
like under a whole [ __ ] ton of quilts
yeah pictures that was funny that was
funny when we had to do it like that i
know and like you would come in there
like over the door and i feel like
we can i remember when we first bought a
microphone we were [ __ ] we were like
man forty dollars for a microphone
that's expensive
remember that that [ __ ] sounded like
[ __ ] it did yeah yeah sounded like [ __ ]
so we ended up having it now we look at
a microphone
if it's [ __ ] under 100 you're like oh
that's a pretty good deal
yeah it's like we have a couple of these
uh yetis
and these were what 80 80 900 something
like that
and then the one that i use for
audiobooks because i just use this for
witching hour and we just use this for
the show but the one i use for
audiobooks which has to be better
is uh um what the [ __ ] the name of it
i can't remember the name of the brand
it's a good one that one was almost
three hundred yes
you know um we uh we ought to go ahead
and get the other microphone out we can
run two
microphones at once can't we um i don't
we thought one of them was bad but it
wasn't bad
it was a software issue remember yeah
and it might be better if i had one of
them over here
i'll have to check and see how that'll
work because i don't know do you guys
ever have any problems hearing me do it
i don't know what it sounds like if
people are on headphones or whatever but
maybe it's good enough yeah it's usually
not i mean as long as you aren't like
walking around the room back there it's
like we can still hear you it's just
like
it just gets a little tinny like if you
move back farther
but because generally i i have it on the
settings
i have it on like the heart-shaped thing
so it's just recording like in a cone
right here
pretty much yetis aren't great
microphones they're just a good web
microphone yeah it's a good like
inexpensive like you get a decent sound
with it but like i said this one
i have done audiobooks with this one
before but it's not quite
as good um so i usually use and i can't
[ __ ] remember it's red
it's a yeah what the [ __ ] is the name of
it i can't remember it starts with that
got the big professional
chords [ __ ] yeah it's got the pop
filter attached to it and all that other
kind of it's got a [ __ ] box that goes
through there there's like a filter
and does all kinds of stuff noise
filters i forgot what all that shit's
called
it's not real complicated you just have
to preset it it's something you can
actually uh
what's it called rda you can i don't
forgot what it's called it's a different
format
it's professional you could you could
yeah a couple of years ago
it'll plug into a sound board if you had
to yeah and do professional
so i just keep that one in there all the
time because that's like
just for audio books i mean it's not as
nice as something that you know a
thousand dollar microphone but [ __ ]
you don't need a thousand dollar
microphone i don't have a thousand
dollars to spend on the microphone
you don't need a thousand dollars no you
don't i think up to a certain
price point like i said now the the one
that that guy i think that one was
almost 300
and that one does sound better than the
yeti
but i think once you get into the three
four 100
range i don't think it's gonna get that
much better like if you spend
more and you'd have more money you'd
have to be a [ __ ]
professional classical
singer in a [ __ ] real super high-tech
studio
to really get any advantages off of a
thousand dollar microphone
yeah i mean it would really happen you'd
have to be an opera singer or something
and you'd have to have a [ __ ] you
know 300 is good enough it's real close
to like a 400 or 500 it's
not a big difference yeah that's right
that's right
and like i said i i haven't had any pr
any issues with
the sound ever since i'd started doing
audio books with those like i haven't
been kicked back or anything yeah we had
to uh get rid of all the old
recordings dude we replaced them all yes
all the old audio books i'm pretty sure
i did
all of them or most of them yeah i don't
think there are any of them out there
that are still in the old
recordings because it sounded tinny yeah
even though
some of those complaints from the old
versions of the recorder are still on
those shows
but that's just part of the game yeah
well and i i put in the description that
the
that the audio had been updated as of
whatever the date was
yes they sound a lot better than they
used to yeah all right so
uh you ready to yeah i'm ready to go
wrap it up you gotta go find pookie she
like she went outside and she's like i'm
gonna go hide bye
so we don't know where she went to she
was trying to uh she was trying to
scratch her way out this morning i don't
know why she must have seen a bird or
some [ __ ]
victor garcia had a [ __ ] flashback to
[ __ ] r kelly's trapped in the closet
that was so again on south park wasn't
it tom cruise had to come out of the
closet
that's right that was [ __ ] funny man
yeah that was like the scientology
yeah well yeah they were saying tom
cruise was gay well yeah and then
another one that people forgot about was
uh um
gay fish remember gay fish the song gay
fish
it was a ripoff on uh kanye west on
kanye west
and he's singing about he's actually
again oh yeah yeah yeah
making love with the other fish that's
right hilarious i remember that you can
find it on youtube
sandra asked how's beijing she's
actually she's a lot better she's doing
a lot better
she's still like she hates medicine yeah
she took the liquid medicine the liquid
medicine that's
gone we yeah we went through all that
already she still has to take those
blue pills though and she hates it
every day like she knows as soon as you
come and get her she's just like no
she knows she has to do it though and i
think she knows it makes her feel better
yeah those pills are reading up on them
and what they do is they
they help they help um
they help [ __ ] liver function a lot
and they can regenerate
a liver and they uh do something about
they
they help remove toxins from
the bloodstream so that's why she feels
better
yeah she even uh yeah she's been
bringing the babies out like
usual she other day i came out of my
office and she like was around the
corner and she snuck out was like wow
like she used to do yeah they get they
give them to dogs and i saw some reviews
some
a lot of people said that you know like
within a few months
that their dogs and cats regained full
liver function after a couple months
i really really hope hopefully we'll see
yeah because she seems like
exactly she seems right back to normal
you can keep them on those pills the
rest of their lives
yeah if the liver doesn't really and
they're not super expensive
so yeah they're not exposed yeah i hope
so i really hope she's gonna be okay
yeah she's an old cat and i'm spending
[ __ ] tens of thousand dollars on a
liver transplant
well i know she gets real sick we'll
just put her down she's she's old
i know she's 15 something and i thought
she was 13.
close to 15 i think it's hard to say but
you know some cats some animals just
they just don't live that long you know
i mean
genetic problems and just whatever that
liver
what happened to her liver may have had
something to do with eating lizards
because i know that she's eating a few
lizards
and lizards can carry something like a
virus
yeah we try to keep them from doing that
but we can't always
catch them pookie usually doesn't eat
them pookie catches them
and then runs to the door with them in
her mouth going look what i got yeah she
doesn't kill anything she catches
uh at first she's not trying to kill it
she she kills it accidentally playing
with it yeah she just wants to play she
brought me the damn flying squirrel and
i said let in
in that flight if if i took it away it
bit the [ __ ] out of me
i thought it was a baby flying squirrel
i didn't realize that flying squirrels
were that size there's
yeah and there's they're tiny they're
like the size of a chipmunk
that poor little squirrel was just like
yeah
yeah i was into dragon's mouth yeah
he was okay though yeah she didn't hurt
she didn't hurt him
she probably she would have eventually
if we hadn't like seen her well she kind
of gets bored as long as it's moving
she'll play with it when it stops moving
she'll get bored with it and walk away
from it yeah and that's how that's how a
lot of the lizards get away
yeah because they're just like oh [ __ ]
they stopped moving i'm dead
yeah they stopped moving and then she's
like yeah she's not anymore yeah
and then they're like a squirrel will do
the same thing yeah
uh eventually they'll [ __ ] get so
terrified they'll stop moving and start
playing dead
and uh sometimes you can't walk away
from them well it's an effective
strategy yeah
that's why a lot of animals because a
lot of times they don't want to eat them
they just want to play with them
yeah you know i don't think the squirrel
knows that i think it's just something
that they that evolved and the behavior
that involved in them
that you only fight for a certain amount
when you can't win the fight then just
kind of give up
and accept it and then a lot of times
you get let go so that gets reinforced
in the gene pool yeah
so they just they go on to [ __ ]
spread that gene honestly i think pookie
mostly
likes to play with the animals but also
she likes to show them to us yeah
like because she because she'll bring it
right to the door look
look yeah and then we're like oh good
one good one but she lets us take it
away
when i walked out there hit the
flashlight on her and saw
two sets of eyes i'm like what kind of
what animal is that she [ __ ]
walks towards me just a little bit and
goes look look at that it's a [ __ ]
squirrel i'm not squirrel uh
a raccoon she's hanging out with a
raccoon they were sitting next to each
other
sitting there on the ground and she just
and she's like look look look
what kind of cat is that
and she'll run after possums and go ugh
she'll run up to it as soon as she gets
to it she stops and goes oh that thing's
nasty
oh look at that thing look at it look at
the [ __ ] raccoons right now the
possums are running trying to get away
[ __ ] funny that's a big rat
[Laughter]
they're both both beijing and pokey are
fascinated by raccoons though
yeah i think they think they're just
like pretty cats
like super cute cats with little burglar
masks i went out
in the back porch and i was walking to
the back door
and it's a sliding glass door just at
night with the light
porch lights on just in time to catch
four raccoons walking in and beijing was
on the damn
chair uh behind the [ __ ] lawn chair
table or whatever you call it
and beijing stands up and sees these
four raccoons coming she looks down like
that and they all just start nose to
nose all four of them and she's sitting
there
hey hey and then what are these things
and you have fluffy tails like me and i
was i was
tripping out she was just like loving on
these four
raccoons and the raccoons are standing
up and looking at her and going wow what
kind of cat is that
and um then the the raccoons saw me and
they all scurried away there's like oh
here's the humans
that's fine cats are hilarious yeah but
evident there's a lot of stuff on
youtube of cats and
cats and raccoons and they evidently uh
they get along
that's so weird you would think that
they would kill each other but no they
get along
yeah i don't know why that is because
raccoons can be mean
yeah depending on if it's a big male
raccoon if it's trapped and scared it'll
fight you
i had to jump into a [ __ ] dumpster
one time and get a raccoon out of a
dumpster
no yeah or it would have been dumped
i got it i was like i'm gonna get this
thing out and i had gloves and [ __ ]
there was a empty cardboard box in there
and i put that cardboard box up around
the corner
in the corner and walked the other way
and tricked him into going to the box
and i shut it
that's how i did it oh again handed the
box out to my buddy and he
took it it was in there fighting
it down he comes up out of the box and
looks at us the box falls over he looks
at us and he goes
just stands there looking at he goes oh
[ __ ] then he runs
he's like there's two of them thanks man
they don't know how long
we don't know how long it was in the uh
dumpster at least two days
oh [ __ ] so you know he was happy to be
out
well i guess so yeah he's like this was
a mistake i got in here because
something smelled yummy and then i
couldn't get it back
out yeah because it was an interesting
learn
it was pretty much an empty dumpster
yeah so there's nothing to climb up on
to get back out
right couldn't jump out the lids were
closed
oh so he went in well at least you got
him out of there guess he'd learned
don't jump into any old dumpster well
yeah hopefully he learned not to do that
yeah anymore he'd get back out
yeah you saved a life then yes
all right so uh that'll do it for
today's
fun stream we'll be back tomorrow talk
about another movie probably
and uh so we'll see you guys later
bye